so I think I figured out why it is that
we have socialists in this country I
think I've solved the mystery I want to
explain that to you but before I do let
me tell you about stamps.com
so here's the thing we're we're all busy
these days right we're too busy we've
got too much going on so something that
feels like a small little errand can
really become a big hassle something
like going to the post office with
everything else you got going on in your
life it's just you don't have time for
that ain't nobody got time for that to
quote Aristotle and we're all looking
for areas where we can kind of
streamline things and make things easier
for us to free up some some precious
time and that's why you need stamps.com
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trips to the post office and
it saves you money with discounts that
you can't even get at the post office I
think that's the best part
Stan's comm basically brings the post
office to your computer and this is a
huge benefit no matter if you're a small
a small office sending invoices if
you're an online seller shipping up
products whatever it is even if you're
just an average an average Joe like me
whatever your postal needs happen to be
Stan's stamps comm can handle that
here's how it works you just use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere it doesn't matter
whatever whatever it is you can do it
once your mail is ready you just hand it
to your mail carrier you drop it in in
the mailbox whatever and it just it
doesn't get much simpler than that and
simple is the key simple as my favorite
thing I didn't mention the best part in
my view or I want to expand on it a
little bit that's the money that you
save with stamps com you get five cents
off every first-class stamp and up to
40% off Priority Mail so stamps calm is
just a no-brainer saving you time and
money and it's no wonder it's not a
mystery why 700,000 small businesses
already use stamps calm that's seven
hundred thousand small businesses use
this so you know that it works so pay
attention to this part this is the
important part right now my listeners
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free PO
and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment so you just have to
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
Walsh
that's stamps.com enter Walsh
stamps.com enter Walsh save time save
money the only problem I guess you'll
have is is figuring out what to do with
all the extra time that you have once
you've saved all that I suggest taking
up beekeeping but I mean you could do
whatever you want with the time stamps
com enter Walsh check it out now ok so
my my 2 year old son has has a routine
at night that he's grown really attached
to and accustomed to and the routine is
that my wife will will bring him into
his room and read him a story and put
him down to bed and then she'll leave
and then I come in separately and I give
him a hug and I say goodnight and and he
really wants that individual attention
from from each of us that's just that's
what his routine is and I need any
parent with the young kid you know that
they get they get a certain routine
especially at night and they need that
routine every night in order to go to
bed and what I do is you know I go in
there and I give him a hug and I always
ask him every night I ask him what did
you do today
no it's the question I ask him every
night even if I was with him all day and
so I know what he did I still ask him
what did you do because I think it's
it's good to try and and teach kids how
to answer a simple question like that
how to remember things sequentially and
recount them to you and it's also funny
and kind of sweet at this age though
because he can't think that way yet I'm
trying to sort of teach him but he's not
not there yet at this age he can't
really remember in a logical sequential
kind of way what happened or what he did
during a particular day so when I asked
him this question he'll always tell me
some story it's always a story that
definitely did not actually occur in
real life during that day so when I
asked him what did you do today he might
say go to jump house or or he might say
zoos
we go to zoo or he'll say that he went
to Nana's house or you know he'll just
make up some story and sometimes you'll
even expand on the story he'll say
Nana's house ice cream ice cream at
Nana's house saying you had ice cream in
Nana's house and he'll say those things
even if he definitely did not do any of
those things but then if we actually go
to like if we actually went to the zoo
and I asked him what you do today he
won't say he went to the zoo he'll come
up with some other other thing and why
is that well because kids when they're 2
years old right they can't distinguish
what they wish was the reality from what
actually is the reality they literally
cannot tell the difference so for him
when you ask him what did you do today
what he hears is what did you wish you
did or what would you like to have done
or just tell me a story like that he
can't tell that's that's how he hears it
he can't tell the difference between
those things so a child at this age
literally psychologically cannot
distinguish desire from reality and
that's one of the reasons why a
two-year-old kid they have these temper
tantrums where they asked for something
and then you don't give it to them right
away and they just have a total meltdown
because they they really don't
understand why it is you know when he
comes in and asks for some juice and you
say well we don't have juice or wait a
minute I'll get you juice in a minute
and he starts melting down it's because
he really doesn't understand that he
wants juice why he's in their juice in
his hand right now he just asked for it
so why isn't there he really doesn't
understand it and so there's this so
everything goes haywire did it in his
brain and then he in any melts down and
freaks out this is also why with kids
little kids they'll they'll set that
they'll say something that is that isn't
true but they aren't you can't say that
they're lying they aren't capable of
lying so if a kid knocks over a glass
and it breaks and the milk spills
everywhere and then you say to them did
you just knock that glass over and they
say no if the kid is 3 years old 2 or 3
years old that's not a lie in the
child's
mind he wishes that he had not knocked
it over and so when he says I didn't
knock it over it's the same thing
because he wishes he hadn't done that it
means that he didn't do that
so as I've noticed this feature in
little kids and it's very endearing and
in pretty hilarious when a child is 2 or
3 but as I've noticed it in in my kids I
can't help but notice how so many adults
in our culture today also do the same
thing and it's kind of scary when you're
a parent and you see the way little
children behave it gives you such an
insight into how adults behave
especially these days in our culture
except it's not nearly as endearing or
funny for adults in fact it's not
endearing or funny at all but it seems
to me that a lot of adults are similar
in that they struggle to see the
distinction between what they want to be
true and what is true so take for
example the alleged grownups who
advocate for the government to forgive
student loans when I hear these people
talking and explaining their point of
view I always think of my two-year-old
son dick they they're acting exactly the
same way they say they say well the
government should just make this go away
a trillion dollars in student loans the
government should just take care of that
I shouldn't have to pay it the
government should pay it money that
people chose to borrow of their own free
will and volition they shouldn't have to
pay that back I shouldn't have to pay
back the government should just take
care of it and then you say you know you
might you might argue back well that
can't happen it would be a disaster the
government can't just do that you can't
take my the money has to come from
somewhere so if you're asking for the
government to forgive your student loans
what you're saying is the government
should take money from people who did
not take out those loans and use it to
pay off the loans that you took out that
can't happen it doesn't make any sense
it wouldn't be fair would be
economically disastrous
just it can't happen it's crazy but the
people advocating this they have no
argument in reply they have no reasons
it's just I want it to be this way so it
should be so you'll notice that their
reasons for why the government should
forgive student loans their reasons
never have anything to do with
feasibility or economics or even or even
really justice or anything like that
it's just their reasons all have to do
with how it would benefit them
personally and so when you're trying to
argue with them about you're trying to
talk about the issue on sort of a
grander scale all they want to talk
about is well well yeah but I mean I'm
having trouble paying my rent because of
my student loans so and you say yeah but
that's so what that doesn't mean what do
you mean so what but I but this is a
problem in my life and so it should just
be solved
socialism is gaining popularity
especially in the younger generations on
this same basis people who just never
their mentality never developed past the
age of two or three there are people who
want socialism to work insist that it
will work because they wanted to not
able to distinguish between what they
want and what actually is so they say we
need to have socialism and you point out
that all of these socialist systems
throughout the last 100 or so years have
resulted in calamity and death on an
astronomical scale you tell them to read
the Gulag Archipelago you tell them to
read about Venezuela look at North Korea
you give all this evidence but it
doesn't matter they want socialism to
bring about a utopia so it will the fact
that it never has before doesn't matter
the fact that it is resulted in in
tragedy and travesty and death doesn't
matter the fact that we can look at all
of these other countries and see real
world
samples and see how horrifying they are
doesn't matter none of that matters you
can show them pictures of the socialist
breadlines and that doesn't matter
because in their minds all they're
thinking is well yeah but I but that's I
want it to be different and so it will
be I think the the green New Deal is the
most prominent and striking example of
this mentality have you ever tried
speaking to a true believer in the green
New Deal
we tried talking to them about it
getting their reasons for why and you
try to explain to well you know that
it's just not possible we can't abolish
air travel and retrofit every single
building in the country and you know
provide everyone an income even if
they're not working we just can't do
that it's just the money doesn't exist
for it it would be to even try would be
a disaster but there is this disconnect
because all they're thinking is yeah but
how great would it be if it did work and
because it would be great if it did work
then it will work so the only remaining
question is how is it that so many
adults have made it to adulthood without
developed without developing the ability
to distinguish desire from reality and I
really have no groundbreaking answer to
that I think that this is just what
happens when kids are never told no
never disciplined never given any
boundaries never taught to cope with
disappointment if you raise a kid like
that they will likely end up in jail or
a socialist and as a parent I'm really
not sure which I would prefer but I
think maybe I'd prefer the former to be
honest but this is this just what
happens if I if I can look at my two or
three-year-old child and see and make
these comparisons between him and adults
well that just shows you it's like it
if it's very cute right now at two or
three but if I never teach him how to
actually cope with reality then that's
that's where it's gonna end up all right
so switching gears here last night there
was in utterly horrifying though
compelling and I think important
documentary that aired the first part of
it aired on HBO it's called leaving
Neverland and it's about Michael
Jackson's monstrous abuse of two young
boys two young boys were now adult men
named Wade Robson and James safe Chuck
Jackson was accused by five boys in
total and this documentary focuses on
two of them and it tells the story about
how Michael Jackson would find these
kids groom them endear himself to their
families kind of set the stage for for
what comes next and then he would make
his move and the sexual abuse when it
began was of course just and it was
described in graphic detail the
documentary but it was as as you would
expect revolting vile evil I mean just
nightmare inducing now but I tell you
what as I was watching this for me the
most shocking aspect of the documentary
aside from the graphic details of the
abuse itself but the most surprising
thing to me as someone who was you know
I was I was a young kid myself when
Jackson's was really at the height of
his fame so I never really paid
attention to I didn't really pay
attention to Michael Jackson I never
listened to his music I didn't really
care about him and the whole thing when
I was a kid I mean I just wasn't paying
attention to it so as I'm watching the
documentary it really surprised me to
see how Jackson was constantly draped
all over young boys in public on camera
constantly all the time it just wise
they've got they've got just reams of
of footage of this guys walking around
with holding hands you know he got his
arm around all these random young boys
he groomed these kids in public for the
whole world to see it and he would have
one male companion who went with him
everywhere it wasn't just like the kid
showed up at a charity event with him
one time is like they would have one kid
who was with him for like a year every
where they would be on private planes
together they would go to all the shows
together they would just always be
together and holding hands having their
arms around each other and it would be
like that for a year and then the boy
would be replaced by by another boy who
looks strikingly similar but often was
younger and this was the this was the
this was the process that would unfold
in public for everyone to see that
Michael Jackson would always have a new
companion was always a young boy they
always looked similar the companion he
never had an adult companion that as far
as anyone could tell and it was never a
girl you know he would never so this
idea what he just loved kids he was a
kid himself you liked hanging up
yeah well didn't I was but so what is it
he never had little girls around him
though if you notice that it was always
little boys always little boys around
the same age everything is the same so I
look at that now it wasn't all that long
ago but I think it's heart I can't even
imagine now a world-famous pop star who
is known to always have young male
friends flanking him friends flanking
him it's just but this wasn't all that
long ago and this was what was happening
in public and that's the thing here you
know
Jackson's deranged cultish idiotic
defenders and and these people really
are just disgusting honestly they are
the people that are that defend Michael
Jackson these people I have so much
disdain for them but they will leap to
the paedophiles defense and they'll
say oh nothing was proved and he was
found innocent in court okay first of
all ii-i've heard that over the weekend
as I've been talking about this on
Twitter a little bit I've heard that
phrase so many times he was proven
innocent
no do you know anything about how the
justice system works in this country he
was not proven innocent that's not what
happens he was not convicted he was
acquitted okay you're either convicted
or not he was not but just because a
world-famous beloved mega-wealthy pop
star with an army of top lawyers managed
to secure an acquittal
rather than be convicted based on
accusations from powerless nameless kids
that does not mean he's actually
innocent okay just because a rich and
famous person can buy an acquittal for
themselves that does not mean that
they're actually innocent so we can use
our brains here which which the jury did
not do in his whatever was 2005 in that
case the jury didn't use their brains
but we can we can use our brains and and
we can see the truth plain as day so
this is the point even if you think it's
possible that five boys would all accuse
him falsely all telling remarkably
similar stories even if you think it's
possible that they're all lying and
really what people are falsely accused
I've said that many times
and there have been recent examples of
people being falsely accused but if you
have five separate children over the
course of a decade coming out and
accusing you of abuse and telling the
same kind of story of abuse with all the
same lurid details well II the chances
that you're innocent are just extremely
low and
I'm trying to think of an example of a
person who was accused five times of
child molestation and was not a child
molester
I maybe you could say I can't think of
an example but even if you ignore that
and if you ignore the fact that he that
he that he paid off he you know at least
one of his accusers so even aside from
that we can still convict him in the
court of public opinion based on the
undeniable and proven facts
so forget about accusations for a minute
there are some undeniable proven facts
facts that even Michael Jackson admitted
to fact number one Michael Jackson a
grown man would seek out young male
companions back number one fact number
two Michael Jackson a grown man would
invite these companions over to his
house which was filled with toys and
amusement park rides and he would endear
himself to their families and he would
give their their parents money and
lavish trips and all this kind of stuff
fact number three Michael Jackson a
grown man would invite these young boys
into his bed and this is something that
he admitted to on TV you could watch the
footage fact number four that bed where
Michael Jackson a grown man slept with
young boys was also right next to his
stash of bondage porn fact number five
that bed where Michael Jackson a grown
man slept with boys was also in a room
behind a locked door at the end of a
hallway that was rigged so that alarms
would go off if anybody was approaching
now those are all established facts
absolute 100% facts and those right
there all by themselves are enough for
any sane person to know that Michael
Jackson was a predator that's all you
need you don't need anything else those
facts alone tell you everything you need
to know unless you are a total absolute
[ __ ] and then you add in the fact that
what do you know five of those those
young boys that Jackson shared a bed
with just so happened to accuse him of
abuse and they
all told remarkably similar stories and
they even described his porn collection
then they even described his genitalia
when you add those things in well then
it just becomes overwhelmingly clear but
my point is that that even if no child
had ever come forward and accused him of
anything I would still say based on the
facts listed before I would still
conclude that this guy was a predatory
creep even with no accusations because
there is no other rational explanation a
man a grown man who seeks out young boys
befriends them that invites them into
his bed
there is no non horrible explanation for
that none at all and we all know that
that's the thing even if you are a
moronic Michael Jackson defender you
know that if anyone not named Michael
Jackson if let's just say Bob Smith or
William Jones or Frank you know whoever
had a had a habit of making friends with
seven-year-old boys let's just say that
there's there's a guy in your
neighborhood look let's let's say all
the same facts apply the same basic
facts except that's not Michael Jackson
it's Bob Jones and he lives in your
neighbor Bob Smith and he lives in your
neighborhood okay let's say there's a
guy Bob Smith lives in your neighborhood
and he likes to befriend seven-year-old
boys and he always has a different
seven-year-old boy companion who are not
related to him not not like that's his
son or even a nephew or just random boys
and he likes teff sleepovers well he'll
invite these young boys over and he
likes to invite them into his bed now if
that if those and those are all facts
about Michael Jackson if those effects
applied to Bob Smith in your
neighborhood you would know with
absolute certainty that he was a creep
and you would call the police and then
he would go to prison because Bob Smith
in your neighborhood wouldn't have the
army of lawyers and you also wouldn't
have the advantage of
jury members who know him and love his
music which obviously when you've got a
guy like Michael Jackson on the jury
you know I ideally you're supposed to
try to find people that have never heard
of him but it's just in in 2005 there
was no way you would find anyone who had
never heard of Michael Jackson so you
know if that was Bob Smith you would
know for certain that he was a predatory
creep and he would go to jail and that
would be it yet as I established it in
spite of this overwhelming evidence that
Jackson was a monstrous horrible
predatory freak in spite of that legions
of Jackson's fans still defend him and
they defend him viciously you know
sending hate mail and death threats to
anyone who discusses his pedophilia
swarming like zombies to defend their
favorite pop star so much so that
they're you know there are a lot of
people just don't even want to touch
this subject because they don't want to
deal with Michael Jackson's idiot fans
well I happen to I don't really care
about that which is why I'm you know but
Minh as I think about this and I just
just trying to wrap my head around these
people who who still defend this guy and
a really revolting thing when I think
about it is that these people can't
possibly be as stupid as they portray
themselves to be the defense's they
offer are so weak and so desperate that
there's no way that they actually find
their defenses convincing like I'm not
kidding a Michael Jackson defender sent
me last night a list of boys that
Michael Jackson did not molest that was
his defense of Michael Jackson said oh
yeah well here's a bunch of boys that
Michael Jackson didn't molest what do
you think about that okay
well first of all how do you know that
he didn't molest those boys second so
what there were plenty of women that Ted
Bundy didn't kill
almost every woman in the world was not
killed by Ted Bundy almost every single
one except for the you know the several
that he did kill so what does that mean
and and and just to go back to the first
point just because a person says that
they were not abused as a child doesn't
mean that they actually weren't and
that's part of the abuse now I know
McCauley cause ever say what Macaulay
Culkin wasn't abused even if he wasn't
whatwhat does so that proves that
Michael Jackson didn't abuse these other
kids who he slept in a bed with and I'm
not saying the Michael did Macaulay
Culkin says he wasn't abusing then you
know okay but um you know only he knows
the other guy who would know is dead now
but mercifully but the fact that we have
to deal with here is that when a child
is groomed from a young age and
brainwashed and manipulated by a monster
like Michael Jackson there's a very good
chance that they'll never say anything
about it I mean this how many times do
you have to see this before you
understand this the way it works people
can be abused and they could wait 50
years to say anything especially if
specially if they're abused as young
children Michael Jackson preyed on kids
who were like seven or eight years old
this is straight-up pedophilia these are
young children and to end to be abused
at that young and that age and and then
on top of that bhaiyya by a guys the
most you know most famous one of most
beloved people in the world you have no
idea what that does to your brain and
what it does to you psychologically so
you could have people who never say
anything be either because they're
afraid or they're confused or even
because they through this brainwashing
they've developed what they think is
sort of a love for their abuser now it's
not really love but they can't tell the
difference because of the trauma that
they've endured and that's that's one of
the really
disturbing things when you watch the
documentary you can see how these two
men who are you know coming out into
telling their story they still appear to
have mixed in with all this with all a
you know anger and the hurt and
everything that they're obviously
feeling there's also appears to be some
kind of like almost affection that they
still have for Michael Jackson and when
they when they you could tell that they
almost are at certain points they're
they're looking back sort of fondly on
certain you know aspects of of their of
their memories and that just shows you
that that's that's the trauma that abuse
does to a person especially when when it
happens at that age when they're so
young so when Jackson's brainless
defenders say well well why did some of
the accusers recant and then later on
they started accusing him again because
they were children okay they were abused
children they were terrified confused
manipulated and that's why
now the other defense
that you hear is that they'll say well
well Michael Jackson was just a child
himself you're just an innocent child
and you know what I mean if you're gonna
offer that again if that's your excuse
for a guy who's who found young boys and
invited them into his bed if your
excuses well he was just a child himself
then you are either incredibly
incredibly stupid or you're not and you
know that what you're saying is crazy
yet you're saying in any way because
you're trying to find an excuse for a
guy's predations of little kids because
you like the way he danced because
that's what this is really about it all
these people love Michael Jett what do
they love about they love that he they
love is dancing and they and then he
made some songs they liked that's that's
all it's it's these people didn't know
him personally they liked his songs I
like his music video he danced really
well in thriller and so based on that
you've decided that no he's not a child
molester you know he he slept in bed
with little boys but but you know this
is a perfectly good reason for that
there's no way that a guy that danced
that well I mean I mean there's no way
he could be a pedophile that's
essentially the logic so what do we what
do we do with this I think the question
is should Michael Jackson's habit of
molesting boys cause us to enjoy his
music less should he be posthumously
shunned and shamed and I would say to
that yes absolutely we should enjoy his
musical in fact I don't know how you
could listen to his music at all given
this and he should be posthumously
shunned and shamed I mean it's a it's a
great tragedy that he couldn't be locked
in a cage in a prison cell when he was
when he was still alive but because we
didn't have that chance then then yes
and his his whole is a state which is
worth billions should be worth nothing
it should be worth $0 and I know that I
have made the opposite argument with
other dead famous people historical
figures in fact just recently I
condemned the efforts to posthumously
shame John Wayne for his racist opinions
that he gave in a magazine 50 years ago
there's a
difference here okay first of all
Michael Jackson grooming and molesting
boys is a much worse offense than John
Wayne sharing wrong opinions second I
have argued forcefully and repeatedly
that the sins of people from the past
has to be understood within the context
of their times we have to understand
things in historical context but there
is no historical context that mitigates
Michael Jackson molesting boys in the
1980s and 1990s third there are you know
historical figures who are accused of
some very serious moral infractions like
Christopher Columbus Columbus for
instance but who like Columbus in my
view still made enormous Lee significant
irreplaceable contributions to our
civilization men who you might say our
civilization would not exist in its
current form if not for them men who
also we should note while possessing
great flaws had great virtues like
courage for instance and I think in
their case even if they also did very
bad things we should still honor them
and remember them and appreciate their
their contributions as a matter of
history but Michael Jackson he just made
some songs people like that that's all
he brought to the world they you know
that's all if he never existed at all
everything would be basically the same
there would be almost no difference
except these families that he destroyed
maybe would still be intact so that
would be the big difference so without
Michael Jackson existing there would be
positive differences in the world but
it's not like if you get rid of
Christopher Columbus and who knows I
mean everything could look different
without Columbus with Michael Jackson
it's not that way so it seems to me that
his evil deeds far far far outweigh his
good contributions contributions which
consist frankly of just some catchy
tunes and that's it and and yeah I mean
music is important and you know it makes
us feel good and all that kind of and
that's fine that's great but it's just
pop music that's all
guys that's all of this and and if
that's all a person brought to the world
and you know in the good category and
then in the bad category you have the
serial molestation of innocent children
then I think that's someone that we just
need to toss out you just there's no
room for them anymore
and there's no reason to remember them
finally or or anything they should just
be forgotten except in the context of
you know using their story as a as a
cautionary tale and that's the other
thing that's one of the reasons why I
said this is kind of an important
documentary is it's a cautionary tale it
shows you how predators operate how they
kind of ingratiate themselves into the
lives and the families of the of their
victims and so that's maybe the most
important that that's that's the one
surface I suppose Michael Jackson
provides us now is that we can go back
and learn something about predators all
right
let's see one other thing well there was
I wanted to mention this I guess maybe
we'll save that for tomorrow all right
Alexandre okay zo Cortez has been
accused of has been accused of leaving a
huge carbon footprint herself even while
she's on this environmental crusade
she's still going around in SUV's and
all that kind of stuff and so I believe
as the New York Post I don't the article
in front of me the New York Post did a
did an article about her own carbon
footprint and how it's much bigger than
the average person and so we'll talk
more about it tomorrow I do think that
that is an important point you know it
seems almost like a cheap kind of thing
now because we hear this over and over
again like we get it by now it's almost
redundant that these environmental
Crusaders you know Al Gore flying around
the world on its private jets and so
forth so we know all that but I do think
it's an important point because when you
look at these prominent environmental
Crusaders and
see that almost all of them are not only
leaving a carbon footprint not not just
a carbon footprint that's about equal to
everyone else but a much larger one I
think it'd be this pattern you begin to
suspect that almost all of the people
who are at the forefront of this
movement almost all of them must not
really believe what they're saying and
so when all the people the forefront of
a movement don't believe what they're
saying then that might tell you
something about the movement itself but
we'll talk more about that tomorrow
because I wanted to get to some of your
emails a few good comments I wanted to
read Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com if you have
any emails you want to send this is from
Paul says Matt absolutely love the show
I have to say when you described your
wife telling a story and mentioned that
she was quote around the time of the
French Revolution I absolutely lost it
and had tears streaming down my face I
was laughing so hard I'd like to share a
finding that I had as a married man I
was talking last week about how when you
know when my wife tells has to relate
when my wife wants to relay information
to me oftentimes she'll say it in the
context of a story which is often a very
good story she's a good storyteller but
she just there's so much additional
information she gives me that I can't
focus in on the really important stuff
and I get in trouble later on because I
don't remember what she said but and I
was saying how this is one of the
fundamental difference between men and
women because women have great memories
and so when women are talking to each
other and they relay information this
way to each other in the form of these
long stories with a lot of kind of
superfluous information added into it
but they remember all of it men are
different so that's why it's important
when you know it's better when you're
talking to a man just make it in bullet
points anyway Paul says one of the
duties I had as had as as husband when
we were first married was taking out the
trash one evening a few years into our
marriage I forgot to set the trash out
and we were stuck with a few bags for
the entire week when my wife discovered
this she exclaimed you never take the
trash out this struck me as odd since I
had never missed taking the trash out
fifty-two times per year for something
like five years
as an engineer I frequently need to
describe problems in terms of
mathematical equations so I describe
this situation in terms of what I call
one of the fundamental equations of
marriage which is her never equals my
always minus one or never W equals
always H minus one those are on the same
time frame that some guys at work wanted
to go out and grab a few beers I'm
pretty sure this was the first time that
this particular situation happened in a
marriage when I got home I heard my from
my wife you were always going out with
your friends I'm sure you see that where
this is going but it end up with one of
our one of the other fundamental
equations of marriage which is her
always equals mine never plus one or
always W equals never H plus one I'm not
claiming that these are the only
equations but they are what I've
stumbled across so far keep up the great
work
well Paul you've lost me on the math
once you get into math you lose me
because I'm a very I am myself a very
stupid person but I think I know where
you're going with this only thing I will
say in fairness to in fairness to wives
everywhere is that I think the always
never thing I think both husbands and
wives are equally guilty of that that's
just one of the classic things that you
get in a marriage and it of course it
never helps the discussion the moment
you're going you always do this or you
never do that it's very like nobody
always does anything right unless you're
saying you always breathe although if
you're complaining about your spouse
always breathing them that's probably a
bad sign about your marriage but aside
from something like that that no one
always does does anything there's no
always there is no never so the moment
you start injecting words like that into
a discussion or an argument with your
spouse then it's just it's not going to
go anywhere because this is just
completely completely off there's and
the other thing you'll what always
happens is one of the spouses says you
will you always do this and then the
other one says okay yeah give me three
examples of me doing that thing and they
can never provide the three examples
right even though you said it was always
so but I think by think men and women do
that I don't know if I don't think it's
just a woman that I think men and women
are are equally as likely to throw out
the always and never
alright this is from Patrick it says hey
Matt I want to start off by saying I
really love your show I appreciate what
you do I tend to agree with you on most
issues and even when I don't
I normally respect how you analyze and
break down your reasoning behind why you
believe what you believe in this case
though I feel the need to call you out
about your reaction to the Kim Trump
summit that you talked about on Thursday
and Friday
I applied rationality and critical
thinking to this issue and I happen to
disagree with you and I don't appreciate
you impugning my character or
intelligence for having a different
opinion about that situation than you do
I believe that it is you who may not be
objectively analyzing the facts of
situation there is no evidence that Kim
jong-un knew about or was directly
involved in the situation regarding otto
warmbier I think that when you get to
that to that scale of a country there's
no one person that can know everything
that goes on inside of that country if
you're somehow omnipotent or have spies
in North Korea that I'm not aware of and
thus have proof that kim jeong-hoon was
involved in what happened to otto
warmbier
then please enlighten us I don't even
like Trump or agree with everything that
he does but I recognize that leaders
have to make hard decisions and they
have to do unpopular things sometimes to
get the job done
what would it gain Trump or the United
States in our negotiations for trying to
denuclearize North Korea for Trump to
publicly call out a malignant narcissist
for being a liar about a situation for
which he has no proof that he is
actually lying trump has no authority to
punish Kim jong-un if he was involved we
already have sanctions on North Korea so
other than giving some people a feeling
of moral superiority what would it
accomplish well Patrick I don't know if
I impugn your character I did perhaps
perhaps impugn the maybe character is
not the right word but I did impune
something about the people who are as I
talked about on Friday the people who
the people who are obsessed with Trump
either positive or negative like like I
discussed there there are some people
who will never defend Trump will never
support anything he does and will always
criticize I know we just said we
shouldn't use always and ever but in
this case I think it applies so there
are some people like that on the left
and I think that's absurd
and just irrational but then on the
right there are also people who Trump
has never and can never and will never
do anything that they will criticize
they'll defend everything he does so I
do impugn that but if that's not you
then I'm not impugning you as far as
this situation listen yes it's true that
even a dictator who has an iron grip
over his entire country like hims wrong
and it's true that he can't know
everything that happens but Patrick I
mean come on but North Korea had an
American citizen in prison and they were
torturing him to death you think the
dictator the country didn't know about
that it's not like they have hundreds of
American citizen they had this one guy
and it was a big deal is a big Nash
International News a big big diplomatic
crisis and you think he didn't know that
the dictator of the country did not know
it's just that defies common sense I'm
sorry he definitely knew it and I think
Trump definitely knows that he
definitely knew it yet he said what he
said on Friday and I agree listen it's
not it's not like we want it's not like
Trump can go over there and start
berating the guy publicly as cathartic
as that may be to put a witness as much
as I'd like to see that I agree it
probably wouldn't help but I'm not
talking about that I'm just saying a
moment of moral courage and clarity even
in an uncomfortable situation would have
been great there rather than backing
down and defending the dictator and
bowing before him it's I go no no he
never could have Oh
chairman Kim my good friend never would
have done it no I think that there's a
wide chasm between that reaction which
is what Trump was doing over there and
you know berating Kim publicly which is
what by the way what Trump did like two
years ago when he was trolling him on
Twitter but I think there's a wide see
Trump has never figured out it
in-between between those two think I
think there's a there's an area in
between a very rational mature morally
clear in-between zone that I think
chump could find and that would be good
for everybody
alright last last email this is from
Travis says hi Matt just saw your most
recent segment where you posited the
question when will the majority stand up
I think this is the most important
question regards to the issue because as
you noted it seems as if the vast
majority of people believe this gender
baiting ideology is insane unfortunately
however I think I have some
understanding as to why most people are
unable to stand up against this agenda
and if I've heard enough of your podcast
I think you'll agree with me the problem
is that we as in the prominent culture
value the individuals in volume all
right to choose whatever end available
this tacit belief that all matters is
the unrestrained act of will unless it
hurts someone else
is the is the all that is left of our
morally vapid language it reminds me of
what I heard you say about how we use
the term consent as the only word left
that we that we use to describe sexual
immorality it seems to indicate our
utterly empty moral grammar that is left
for us in this increasingly nihilistic
age yeah I think moral grammar that's
that's that's the right way of looking
at it yeah I do think I do think that
this is there's always there's kind of a
paradox here because on one hand our
culture seems to value choice and it
sort of made an idol of choice to the
point where you can choose to kill your
child you can choose your own biological
identity but then on the other hand do
we see so many areas where choice
particularly in in the areas of
religious liberty and free speech or
choice is constricted so we value choice
so much that you should be able to
choose to kill your child choose your
own magic biology but if you're a if
you're a Christian business owner you
can't choose to not make a cake for a
gay wedding so there is always that any
time you try to boil any boil it down
and get to the heart of the matter with
our culture it's never quite as simple
as that because they're always exception
like we're always looking for okay we
know things are going off track but what
what are the new rules
our culture what are they exactly and
you think you stumble on one of them
okay well one of the new rules is you
can choose whatever you want whatever
you want to choose is okay but then you
realize that well no you could choose
whatever you want as long as your choice
is one of these things over here not one
of these and I think that's just what
happens in a in a in a confused society
that's sort of the point really is that
there are no fundamental principles or
rules or anything everything is just
kind of conflicted confusion reigned
supreme but thank you for the email
we'll leave on that somewhat depressing
note and I'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed